what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
okay we're getting into x-men deadly
Genesis and to be honest there are a
couple of stories that we've left out so
far a lot of those stories are because
I'm just kind of pacing them out to
cover them later on
for example uncanny x-men the first
Forsaken that deals with the idea of
storm moving to Wakanda and taking up
residence in Africa then of course
there's a Black Panther story which
follows that up where storm of Black
Panther get married there's also cable
and Deadpool like bosom buddies and
living legends and so on and so forth
we're gonna cover that when the when
cable and Deadpool drop or at least when
Deadpool 2 comes out and that brings us
to what it is we're gonna do next
so right now x-men deadly Genesis leads
into a few stories I mean really x-men
deadly Genesis kind of wraps up the
decimation branding so to speak which is
to say the aftermath of House of M and
it starts moving the x-men into the new
era of storytelling which is really I
call it like the Dark Age of the x-men
and that goes into things like Messiah
Complex Messiah War and all that kind of
cool stuff you know but because of the
fact that Deadpool 2 has been moved up
to May from June or July or whatever was
supposed to be one of the things that
I'm thinking about doing is going back
to the mid 90s and covering the story of
x-men of Nate gray after the events of
Age of Apocalypse and covering the solo
series and then running into cable and
Deadpool so regardless the cool thing
you remember when it comes to the after
you know the the House of M aftermath
and really when it comes to like the
x-men titles as a whole for the most
part they're really just kind of
stand-alone you don't have to read
through all the x-men publications and
again I'll provide a reading order for
everything that happens between house of
M running up two deadly Genesis so you
guys can kind of pick and choose what
you want to read but you can read them
in isolation if you want to for example
if for whatever reason you're interested
in like multiple Man and x-factor you
can just read the x-factor stories you
know if you really care about the x-men
you could read uncanny x-men new x-men
different things like that there's a lot
of stuff that you can do when it comes
to picking and choosing what it is that
you want to cover but deadly Genesis is
a red comm so for those of you guys who
have been on my channel for a while or
you're new to comedy books or something
like that and you've heard me reference
the phrase of a retcon this is that in
real time so you're literally gonna be
watching it unfold in real time now what
this does is it picks up with regards to
the you know office of national
emergency well the whole idea behind
this was that following the events of
decimation when a Scarlet Witch stripped
98 percent of the mutant population of
their powers the office of national
emergency mobilized and then they
basically stationed sentinels around the
Xavier Institute to keep anybody from
going in and to keep anybody from
getting out
so the x-men are prisoners but they're
also protected from any external threats
but regardless of the circumstance what
we do is we pick up out in space with a
giant chunk of the earth that was
catapulted into space and it's a guy who
basically wakes up and this is cool
because when this person wakes up what
he does is he basically obliterates the
entirety of this astronaut team and then
in turn goes into their ship and starts
analyzing everything going on only to
find out that he's in the 21st century
and this is cool because again we'll
figure out who this guy is because he's
actually crazy powerful but from a year
we pick up with you know how each
individual person is largely dealing
with not only the events of decimation
but the vanishing of Charles Xavier
remember when it came to the main House
of M storyline one of the things that
was established was that Charles Xavier
had died you know well at least it was
believed that he had died nobody could
find Charles Xavier and for the most
part he's just largely been presumed
dead and that was a big question people
were asking where's Professor X and was
he just wiped from existence how did he
die that was a lot of the questions that
were being asked here now of course
picking up with Emma Frost and of course
the use of cerebro which is the huge
computer system they use to basically
analyze mutants across the planet
different things like that this is
basically one of those attempts where
Emma Frost goes in every day and sees
whether or not there were new mutants
who were popping up because remember
from their perspective the number was
reduced but beasts made a really really
good point one of the things that Marvel
does is they'll use like real world
science but only when it's convenient
and this is one of those things where
it's convenient when they basically say
look you know mutant power whether it's
telepathy whether it's reality warping
whether it's energy projection or
what-have-you
it takes a physical form when you shoot
energy out that energy comes out like it
impacts things if it can impact
something it has mass and according to
you know the law of conservation of
matter
maths can't simply just disappear
because of the fact that these powers
whether it was telepathy that was
influencing the mind of others you know
whether it was energy production someone
who can just like shoot energy out of
their body or something along those
lines that energy had to have gone
somewhere
I can't simply just vanish now as we
know that energy is orbiting Earth is
just nobody's really aware of it most
likely because it's kind of a you know
noncorporeal form and it's just kind of
out there and you know just it's not
necessarily detectable regardless of the
circumstance with Emma Frost going into
cerebra and trying to analyze whatever
mutants are out there she's suddenly hit
by this massive blast of energy that
actually knocks her unconscious and the
first question everybody has is one of
the world's going on here because
remember Emma Frost is one of the most
powerful
tallip house in the world and in fact
right now at this moment with Charles
Xavier out of the picture she's the most
powerful telepath on the planet the fact
that somebody was able to overwhelm Emma
Frost and send her into a catatonic
state is insane because it means that
their power is so extreme that her mind
couldn't handle all the energy that was
put off but the fact remains here
because this energy signature emanated
from a shuttle which is since
crash-landed into the earth of course
the x-men respond the other half of this
is that varying members of the x-men
begin to see these like horrific images
for example Kitty Pryde sees a dead body
Nightcrawler is forced to basically
relive his experience living in West
Germany and this is kind of a big deal
because what this means is that all
these different mutants are basically
being forced to kind of relive some of
the most horrific moments in their lives
once they also arrive on with the scene
they end up finding out like this giant
hand was basically reached out of the
ground and you know grabbed this space
shuttle to keep it from smashing into
bits but at this point we kind of pick
up with with a couple things that are
going on the first is with Sean Cassidy
and the second is with the arrival of
the x-men now Sean Cassidy has been in
Marvel Comics for quite some time and he
was a Chris Claremont creation I want to
say but he goes by the name of banshee
and he's actually the love interest of
more McTaggart who's long since died in
the realm of Marvel Comics but Sean
Cassidy of course was was head of like
Cassidy keep and part of like the whole
Cassidy family but because of the fact
that more has been gone for quite some
time when Cassidy are you know when Sean
basically kind of has these visions
where he sees Maura then the question is
what in the world's going on so of
course like anybody he chases after her
now the exact same thing happens with
the x-men with regards to like Cyclops
and Rachel summers and so on showing out
with his shuttle crash and then Cyclops
seeing Jean Grey and chasing after her
now of course once Cyclops and Wolverine
chased after Jean Grey because of course
you know back in the day they were both
in love with her they turned the corner
only to find out that Rachel Summers has
been captured and she's being held by
this super powerful guy now picking up
with Sean Cassidy for a second this kind
of a mental image of more McTaggart that
he's seen has led him to this office
that she had that he never really knew
about and inside this office she kind of
has like this diary where she basically
talked about how terrible of a human
being Charles Xavier was that he was a
horrible person he was manipulative he
was duplicitous but he didn't really do
anything that wouldn't benefit him now
this is huge because this is one of the
first times in Marvel Comics where they
basically come along and they say that
while Charles Xavier on the on the
outset was like really firm and really
harsh with students with regards to
their training but was more of a loving
father figure this is them coming back
and saying actually he was a horrible
human being he was a terrible person and
it's really really interesting because
when this story first dropped things
like this were huge but the fact remains
here that with with regards to the
current moment in the x-men dealing with
you know Rachel summers who's been
captured this guy dominates the x-men I
mean it's crazy well really at Cyclops
and Wolverine but like dominates it in
their entirety like he levitates
Wolverine you know knocks him
unconscious he slows down the impulses
to the brain of Rachel summers
effectively knocking her out but the
coolest Display of power this is one of
the things that I love the most is when
Cyclops goes to shoot his optic glass
the guy forces the blast to go around
him and right back to Cyclops which is
cool because we've never seen a person
control optic beams like that before and
you know initially when I saw this I was
like okay so this guy's like a reality
warper which is crazy but he's not he's
not really a reality warper but he
almost might as well be because of the
kind of things that he can do but the
fact remains here that we end up having
the Office of National Emergency
responding due to the fact that the
x-men had basically left the grounds
without permission more or less they
just kind of you know flew the coop
without telling anybody and of course
you know once they arrive Cyclops and
out Rachel summers have been taken and
Wolverines the only one left and so
coming from here it's kind of a
straightforward moment in this sense
that Emma Frost and the other x-men fly
over to where the military's hanging out
at where they're holding like Wolverine
and so on and Emma Francis uses their
telepathy in order to free Wolverine and
that's really about it I mean it's it's
pretty straightforward in terms of what
we would expect for them to break
Wolverine out the cool thing about this
comes with Rachel summers and Cyclops
now we'll talk about Rachel summers here
in a second because she's a character
that we really really really need to
explain in order for you guys to
understand where it is as you know her
character's coming from and why she's
here but the initial exchange between
the two of them is that you know with
with this guy basically using his powers
to slow down the brain impulses of
Rachel summers it's all she can do to
stay awake but the other half of this is
that where she and Cyclops are talking
to one another what we end up finding
out is this guy shut off the powers of
Cyclops now technically speaking this
should not be possible and and in truth
it's kind of interesting because this
means a couple of different things one
it means this person can control the
mind of Cyclops and effectively turn off
its powers but Cyclops those powers
don't work that way if there's any
scenario where Cyclops has his visor off
and his eyes open optic beams are gonna
come flying out because his eyes are
portals to another dimension and so what
this seems to indicate is that this guy
was basically you know
shutting off cyclopses powers blocked
access to his eyes being portals to this
other dimension and again if that's the
case it's still pretty extreme but for
the character of Rachel summers I want
to talk about her for a second so Rachel
summers is basically a time-displaced
character one of the things that we've
talked about when it comes to Marvel
Comics is the nature of like alternate
realities Marvel uses something called
branch universe theory Marvel basically
says there's a singular universe there's
well there's the main Marvel Universe
and then at some point along the line
and you know events will take place like
spider-man will get the venom symbian
and the Fantastic Four will get their
powers and Charles Xavier will form the
x-men or something along those lines but
like an event will occur that will
branch off to a different universe and
sometimes it creates a new universe
sometimes it's the guaranteed future of
the existing universe for example the
guaranteed future of the main Marvel
Universe was Days of Future past at some
point in the future mystique was gonna
form a new Brotherhood of Evil Mutants
and they were going to assassinate
senator Robert Kelley more McTaggart the
mutant geneticists and Charles Xavier
and response humanity would jumpstart
the Sentinel program the Central's will
become autonomous and they would
basically conquer North America that was
the absolute future what Chris Claremont
also said is in this future this Days of
Future past landscape Jean Grey and
Scott Summers would have a daughter
named Rachel and Rachel would have all
the powers of Jean Grey and none of the
powers of her father the result is that
Rachel summers would use her powers to
send the mind of Kitty Pryde into the
past and stop Days of Future past from
happening now this is where Marvel began
to experiment with the idea of the
multiverse because the questions fans
had is okay if the Days of Future past
is a guaranteed future and then Rachel
summers sends the mind of Kitty Pryde
into the past to stop the Days of Future
past then it creates a paradox if the
Days of Future past is stopped then why
would Rachel summers send the mind of
Kitty Pryde into the past to stop a
future that never happens and so what
Marvel did is he said well it's an
alternate reality now because of the
fact that Days of Future past was
stopped now it's an alternate universe
and that alternate universe
Days of Future past continues on just
like it always did but the the
guaranteed future in the main Marvel
Universe is still unwritten now we don't
really know where that future is going
to hold and so because of that Marvel
started using that as a way to basically
explain all these alternate universes
all these alternate realities but
because of the fact that the Days of
Future past became an alternate universe
after it was stopped Rachel summers
didn't understand why her future didn't
change and so in an effort to understand
why it didn't change she travelled into
the past
because she went back she basically
traveled along this line and then back
to the point before Days of Future past
was supposed to happen that before the
assassination attempt basically my
mystique in the Brotherhood of Evil
Mutants what it meant is that she jumped
from her universe into the main Marvel
Universe and into the past of the main
Marvel Universe and so that created a
story called Days of Future present
alongside like adult franklin richards
showing up going insane different things
like that but the whole idea behind this
was that with Rachel summers in the
present day she was one of those
characters that Marvel had just kind of
brought in and then never really knew
what to do with and so she was rolled
over onto like the Excalibur team
different things like that but she's
just kind of been free-floating in the
Marvel Universe ever since because
nobody ever really knew what to do with
her she was originally designed to kind
of be a stand-in for Jean Grey but fans
immediately rebuked it they were like we
do not want anyone but Jean Grey and so
eventually of course Jean Grey made a
return different things like that and
Rachel summers relationship with Jean
Grey was a little tenuous you know but
it was still a pretty cool scenario but
the fact remains that's why Rachel's
here so having said that hopefully we
didn't know we didn't burn your mouth
your mind out too bad we didn't fry your
brains but at this point we pick up with
havoc with Alex Summers now Alex Summers
is actually a pretty cool character when
it comes to his whole story I mean he
just kind of shoots energy and different
things like that the fun fact about this
is that he and Cyclops are immune to the
others powers because the brothers so
it's actually a cool little caveat when
it comes to the two of them but the cool
thing about Alex summers is that this
deals with the idea of Iceman Bobby
Drake and then Lorna Dayne pilars and
the cool thing was that originally he
was havoc in pilars who were together
and then she bailed on him for body
Drake and it was kind of cool because
that really went into like x-factor that
line of storytelling the kind of dealt
with this whole tenuous love triangle
the fact remains is really just you know
Alex summers being forced to relive
these darker memories that he was really
just kind of rather avoid now the other
half of this is that again this guy
shows up and just kind of taunt Cyclops
to a degree basically saying I know
everything about you I know everything
that makes you who you are
we've met before you just don't know it
and so again it's kind of cool when it
comes to these characters interact with
one another because what we ultimately
end up having is Sean Cassidy you're
reaching out to Nightcrawler and and
Wolverine is saying hey look I have
something you guys need to see it's
effectively the last will and testament
of Mora McTaggart and so you guys have
to be aware of this what we end up
having is that the actual black birth is
basically being controlled and she's
gonna fly directly into the plane that
you know Shaun Cassidy's flying on he
basically jumps out and he attempts to
try to stop the plane which he might
have been
to do using his voice but it's just not
powerful enough and the result is that
he's actually killed in the explosion
which is big I mean it was one of those
things where if you were only reading
uncanny x-men then basically you had
house of aim you had destination and
then like three story arcs later Sean
Cassidy dies and it's not really often
that Marvel kills off an x-man like that
at least you know a one that's been
around for so long and so it's kind of
crazy because the response is you know
from the x-men okay so anybody who looks
at this crime scene is basically gonna
say the x-men's blackbird tried to fly
into a commercial aircraft a mutant
jumped down and was killed in the
explosion what are the x-men doing and
they were immediately gonna come in and
they're gonna start storming the place
you guys remember the office of national
emergency kind of takes precedent here
and so while it is one of those things
of you know hey we're here to keep you
safe it's also we can raid your house
any time you want to we're basically
gonna have the Office of national
emergency raid the place trying to
figure out what in the world is going on
why someone took the Blackbird and try
to fly it into another facility now
picking back up with Alex summers with
havoc the cool thing about this too is
we end up having this sort of mental
image that he picks up when he sees
Charles Xavier talking to Corsair now
course eros is a really really cool
character him and the starjammers we're
actually really really fun and he was an
attempt by Chris Claremont back in the
70s and 80s to kind of expand the
greater Marvel landscape remember when
it comes to like the model cosmos one of
the things that we talked about is that
there were a lot of people who were
working on building the marvel cosmology
but it wasn't a cohesive effort it's not
like Chris Claremont sat down with jim
Starlin roy thomas i said okay so like
how do we flush this out it was one of
those things where they each contributed
their own piece in isolation from the
other and so course eric was basically
the father of Scott Summers and Alex
summers now what's going on is that this
whole idea at least in terms of Charles
Xavier talking to Corsair what he's
really saying is Scott Summers and Alex
summers they can't know you know and it
seems to be you know seems to indicate
that he's selling Corsair
you can't tell them that you're their
father that's the the impression that's
being put on we're actually gonna find
out is that's not necessarily the case
not only that with regards to you know
everything going on with Scott and
Rachel summers what we end up finding
out is these psychic images that are
being put into the minds of people are
being done by this guy he's effectively
seizing control of Rachel summers mind
and then forcing her to put all these
images into everybody's head now a lot
of this is because of the fact that
Charles Xavier kind of left the psychic
imprints what it does is it allows this
guy to use a telepathic abilities of
Rachel summers to scan the Xavier
Institute and grab these
moments from either his own life or the
life of Xavier when he was there and
then broadcast those images into
people's minds or take some of the most
horrific moments from their own
experiences and forced them back into
those people's minds so it's basically
this guy pushing the powers of Rachel
summers in order to instigate his own
ends but not only that the Rachel
summers provides these little tidbits
where she says look you know when this
guy was controlling my mind I was also
reading his a little bit and I've
learned that he trained with the x-men
as there is these small little tidbits
this guy was at some point along the
line in x-men but piecing together this
this you know this video of more
McTaggart after raiding the crash site
and basically grabbing what it was a
banshee was bringing beasts and
wolverine kind of break it all down and
in this last little moment what more
McTaggart says is that Charles Xavier
was a terrible guy because he had gone
to more McTaggart and asked to use her
x-men and then got them all killed now
this is a very important part of her
characters history because with more
McTaggart she was a mutant geneticist
but it was one of those things where she
also helped to harbor and find mutants
that were basically kind of cast offs
now whenever it was as she found
characters like Wolfsbane were somebody
along those lines the characters it
would basically go on to form the new
mutants Charles Xavier would serve the
purpose of being a training ground for
them so more McTaggart in Charles Xavier
were actually quite the team and it was
really cool and so what this does is
this jumps back into the whole idea of
the Battle of krakoa
now longtime x-men fans will be well
aware of this and in fact as soon as
this was called x-men deadly Genesis
they were like giant-size x-men number
one this goes up to the nature of the
x-men right and we talked about this
before when Stanley Jack Kirby Roy
Thomas you know these major contributors
I think Alan fine when they were working
on the x-men stories back in like the
1960s and going into the early 1970s the
x-men were not popular after about 63
issues running over the course of like
seven years the comic was canceled and
then reprints were issued for the next
37 comics this ran into 1975 when Marvel
relaunched his giant-size x-men number
one by Len Wein
and the whole idea is this whole the
story of krakoa and this was basically a
living Island it was a sentient Island
that had captured the x-men the original
x-men of Jean Grey and Scott Summers and
Iceman beast and angel and Charles
Xavier had to form a second team which
is where he brought in the new
generation of x-men Colossus
Nightcrawler Wolverine all those guys
the ones that you're most familiar with
with regards to the x-men roster the
result is that with those newer
characters being rolled in with them
being brought in what it meant is that
fans kind of got the best of both worlds
they got a more diverse lineup of x-men
combined with the x-men
were already used to now eventually that
went out into Bob Layton's whole you
know initial launch of x-factor with
like the first like five issues and then
Walter Simonson Louise Simonson took
over and they wrote it for a little
while but the fact remains here that
this is how this all kind of kicked off
and this is basically what ends up
happening in this store we have this
flashback of sorts where Charles Xavier
shows up to Tamura McTaggart and says
okay my x-men have been captured and the
psychic League I had with them has been
cut off but here's the last few images
that I saw before that happened and it
was the x-men doing the best they could
but the problem is that it seemed as
though the x-men it had been killed or
had been captured and so the result was
that the desire of Xavier was to find a
way to bring them back now following
this what Xavier did is he had gone to
more McTaggart and said I need to use
your x-men team and so in effect this
was a secret x-men team that nobody ever
knew about the first of these members
was a girl named sway and so I had the
ability to like slow down or stopped on
in a localized space meaning it was only
in like a small vicinity and so
basically it would be like in a bubble
and so if you traveled outside her
sphere of influence ty would pass just
like normal but after sway came a
character by the name of Petra and Petra
was basically a Geo morphine ishii could
alter the structure of Earth she could
basically create things she was able to
evolve a coal into a diamond different
things like that but she was basically
able to manipulate the planet Earth
following this is the character of
Darwin we've already done an Origin
video on him but Darwin was basically a
guy who could adapt to any circumstance
he could adapt to anything it didn't
matter what it was if it was fire he
wouldn't really feel it his body would
adapt so the fire wouldn't burn him if
it was dark he would develop you know
night vision I mean his body would
physically adapt to any situation but
one of the more powerful versions of
these characters and one of most
powerful characters on this team was a
kid named Gabriel and nobody really knew
anything about Gabriel's past all they
knew was that he was an orphan somewhere
along the line but his power was to
manipulate energy and it didn't matter
what that energy was exotic normal
whatever he could control it and
manipulate it so if you had like a gun
and you shot a gun at him that bullet
lets off kinetic energy he can
effectively stop it that's why one of
the arguments that's made is a Vulcan
borderlines
on reality warping because everything is
composed of energy and if he can
manipulate exotic energy in the form of
energy blast or something like that what
would stop him from manipulating the
energy of the universe and so if it's
pushed high enough he could be a reality
warping character on the highest order
because he would be manipulating the
energy of the universe as
chose to just energy beams and different
things like that so again Charles Xavier
basically enlists these kids as hey look
I need your help we have to go rescue
the original x-men they're immediately
on board because they're all vying to be
part of the x-men and so Charles Xavier
instead of training them in real time
throws him into the mindscape but
doesn't tell them and this is where
Charles Xavier starts to demonstrate
this kind of duplicitous dishonest
nature in the sense that as far as you
know Darwin and Gabriel and Petra and
swag as far as they're aware it's real
everything they're experiencing is real
but Xavier is basically tricking them
and not necessarily telling them the
truth but the reason why is because
they're on a tight schedule tom is in
such short supply
Xavier does not know how long the
original x-men are going to last and he
needs them to be rescued as fast as
humanly possible and so trading these
characters in the mindscape seems to be
the most efficient way to do it but it's
not and so what ended up happening is
Charles Xavier had basically sent these
kids out into a mission and they all got
killed and so what we end up having is
Scott Summers and we end up having
Rachel Summers who basically make their
way out of this holding facility that
you know that this guy was putting him
in and we find out this is Gabriel
summers that this is the energy
manipulator that we were seeing and he's
also the brother of Scott Summers she's
a brother of Cyclops this Cyclops never
knew about now the cool thing about this
is we do have an origin story on Vulcan
I'm pretty sure either it's an origin
story or it's an Omega beyond Omega
level video
I can't before one but basically he's
not born of Earth instead what ended up
happening is in the history of Cyclops
in and have it Alex summers where you
know they were basically kind of thrown
out of a plane by Corsair when the old
Corsair and his wife were being
kidnapped by the Shiar Empire and in
turn you know Cyclops and have it were
given parachutes and they were said hey
get to safety you know what have you
were Corsair and his wife were taken by
the Shiar empire to basically be thrown
into a workforce but what we ended up
finding out was that Cyclops his mom was
about two months pregnant by the time
that Gabriel had popped up and so the
result was that when they were in the
Shiar empire she effectively gave birth
to him and then he in turn was thrown
into a matrix where his growth was sped
up and then he was just kind of forced
into a work him now eventually he was
able to make his escape he arrived back
on earth the rest is history but the
idea was that he was just kind of
inducted into the x-men and that was
really about it and so following this
because of the fact that he's made such
a huge display and the fact that you
know the office of national emergency is
able to lock on to his energy signature
after realizing that he's the one that
Cynthia said the Blackbird crashing into
banshee effectively killing him he of
course overpowers
the entirety of the you know this
Sentinel and kind of obliterates
everybody but his whole stance here his
whole goal is to draw out Charles Xavier
which works because when he goes to Muir
Island what we end up finding out is
that Charles Xavier is alive the Charles
Xavier is not dead not only that Charles
Xavier when he shows up basically
confirms everything that that Gabriel
summers has been saying that like yes
Gabriel summers is the brother of
Cyclops yes Gabriel summers was one of
the egg one of the members of the secret
x-men team that no one was supposed to
know about and so again it's a huge deal
because what ends up happening is that
in response to this all the other x-men
basically starts showing up it was kind
of this huge audience that Gabriel
Somers was shooting for in the first
place the problem with this is that
where Gabriel Summer says show everyone
the truth use their powers show everyone
the truth where Charles Xavier shows up
with the ability to walk he also shows
up without his powers and so he can walk
around but he can't use telepathy and
this was kind of like a curses that he
really kind of interprets it as The
Scarlet Witch said fine I'll give you
your legs back but I'm gonna take away
your powers just like 98% of the rest of
the mutant population and so the result
is that we end up having this branching
scenario that takes place you know where
Rachel summers steps up and says okay
fine you can use my mind to broadcast
the truth into the minds of everybody
else and again this is what we fought
end up finding out the whole situation
that this Gabriel Sommers led x-men team
did show up they did seem that rescue
the original x-men but Cyclops was the
only one who was able to get away with
the help of the original team where
Cyclops took off you know where he was
told go find help that the reality of
the situation was that for Gabriel
summers and for Charles Xavier himself
now this x-men team was seemingly
obliterated the living Island had
basically adapted itself to all of their
attacks
it killed sway it killed Petra you know
it seemed to kill Darwin and it seemed
to kill at Vulcan at least that seemed
to be the case the problem with this was
that while this battle was going on and
these younger xmin were being killed
Charles Xavier modified the memories of
Cyclops
so the Cyclops would believe the island
sent him back to the x-men to find more
mutants which is what the original
giant-size x-men number one story told
us and so what we end up finding out
here is a Charles Xavier
mess with the - Cyclops tricked him into
believing something happened that didn't
actually happen and in turn the rest of
the mutants that were left on that
island they all effectively died now
Gabriel Summers in Darwin technically
lived but nobody else knew that and so
when Charles Xavier had rounded up this
new generation of x-men Colossus
Nightcrawler Wolverine so on and so
forth and sent them to the island
Cyclops to rescue the original x-men
team where that version was successful
and Jean Grey took the giant landmass
and shot it into space what they didn't
know is that Vulcan and Darwin were
still in that chunk of land and so
because of that they were basically sent
out there you know and they were just
kind of floating in space
Darwin basically merged with with with
Gabriel summers in order to keep him
alive and then they've just kind of
float in there ever since because of the
fact because of the events of house of M
with this massive amount of energy being
given off by the 98% of meetin's that
lost their powers it woke up Gabriel
summers it kicked him up out of this you
know catatonic state and then he in turn
went on this warpath because he
remembered virtually everything and the
question was why doesn't anybody else
know and so as a result of this darwin
basically reconstitutes himself more or
less because it's Darwin and in response
to this with Cyclops learning the truth
that his mind had been tricked by Xavier
that Xavier was being duplicitous he was
lying
Cyclops kicks him out of the Xavier
Institute and says you're no longer
welcome here this works because remember
Cyclops and Emma Frost had been running
the Institute following the vanishing of
Charles Xavier they've been running it
for quite some time not only that as far
as Cyclops says he says you're not a
mutant you don't have to live with the
anymore so you don't really even have a
place here if we've told every person
this that's not a mutant that they can't
come here that same rule has to apply to
you so you have to leave and so what
this does is it sets in motion the story
called rise and fall of the Shiar Empire
where basically Gabriel summers races
into space in order to gain vengeance
against the Shiar Empire who are
responsible for the death of his mother
and the presumed torture of his father
you know Corsair and so on and so forth
but without being said guys we're gonna
bring this video to an end if you are
new here to come as explained make sure
you guys have the sub button to become
part of the robb cork if you guys enjoy
this video make sure you drop a like and
I will catch you all later peace
[Music]
you